police in new zealand have shot and
killed a man who'd stabbed and injured
six people at a mall in auckland uh the
country's prime minister jacinda are
down has described the attacker as a
terrorist who was known to new zealand
authorities as an extremist this is what
she had to say about the attack a short
time ago
the terrorist is a sri lankan national
who arrived in new zealand in october of
2011.
he became a person of national security
interest from
2016. we have utilized every legal and
surveillance power available to us to
try and keep people safe from this
individual
many agencies and people were involved
and all
were motivated by the same thing trying
to keep people safe
i know there will be many questions
about this case and we need to confront
and address each and every one of them
and they will as a matter of course and
good practice be multiple inquiries
including the ipca and importantly the
coroner's inquiry
it is not my intention though to wait
for these reports to release what we can
but they will provide additional insight
into this attack